we can no longer satirize foxnews
because they are beyond satire Fox News
is now a parody of itself down to the
last detail
including the host wearing a gigantic
gaudy cross necklace on the eve of
Easter I'm talking about depraved
diabolical and delusional Fox News host
Jeanine Pirro she may this weekend have
hosted the most weaponized single
episode of a fox news program ever we've
got the corona virus pandemic reaching a
fever pitch 2000 Americans a day are
dying we have no idea how to prevent a
second wave in the fall unless we just
keep the shutdown going disinformation
about the virus is spreading faster than
ever and on the eve of Easter judge
Jeanine was able to put a slate of
guests together that puts previous Fox
News propaganda to shame judge Jeanine
wearing again a comically oversized
cross necklace of course it was the day
before Easter invited Donald Trump Trump
propagandist Peter Navarro who's been
spreading endless disinformation about
the virus and Republican congresswoman
Marsha Blackburn a top right-wing bomb
thrower who never came across a lie she
wasn't willing to tell it's not clear if
judge Jeanine was drunk during this
episode she was drunk during an episode
a week or two ago but you almost had to
be drunk for this television to be
tolerable and what is with the gaudy
crosses by the way I just don't
understand that here are some of the
highlights let's dig right into it Trump
talking about reopening the economy
saying it will be based on facts but
also on instinct which is really scary
the Trump seems to have some of the
worst instincts of world leaders in
American presidents here is judge
Jeanine teeing up a softball for Trump
and Trump answering it as if he is the
great thinker that he believes himself
to be when you make that decision I mean
where do you go within you what is it
that you dig deep for to come up with a
decision aside from all of the people
surrounding you
well Janine I think it's going to be the
toughest decision that I've ever made if
you know I really hopefully that I never
will have to make but
it's certainly the toughest decision
that I've ever made and I hope that I'm
going to make the right decision I'll be
basing it on a lot of a lot of very
smart people a lot of professionals
doctors and business leaders there are a
lot of things that go into a decision
like that and it's going to be it's
going to be based on a lot of facts and
a lot of instinct also whether we like
it or not there is a certain instinct to
it but we have to get our country back
Trump will be deciding on instinct
that's really really bad and we should
be horrified by that because Trump's
instinct was we would have 15 cases
which would quickly go to zero this
would wash away like a miracle in April
not that we would have tens of thousands
of deaths already so then in comes
Trump's economic adviser Peter Navarro
Navarro has been going around in media
recommending medications for coronavirus
he's an economist and a highly partisan
bomb thrower certainly not qualified to
recommend medications but he goes on Fox
News and does exactly that including
even recommendations for specific doses
of medication take a look and then we
went to some additional cities down line
a lot of them read like NFL franchises
you know it's Baltimore it's Washington
it's Houston and also in addition the
Veterans Administration asked for a
million doses we got that to them and
DOD won and Department of Defense wanted
at a million doses we got that to them
so there's demand out there and there's
a protocol and let me just say one thing
the protocol in the FDA it's very clear
what they're doing it's a five-day
protocol you take a double dose the
first day next four days a single dose
and I think well let's see what the
scientific evidence says of course
they're talking interchangeably about
chloroquine and zithromax
I believe when he says double dose one
day followed by a single doses that's
your typical z-pak which appears not to
work in conjunction with chloroquine and
it can actually cause cardiac issues and
when Peter Navarro says protocol Fox
News viewers will hear that and think
this is something that's been actually
tested for and calibrated for Corona
fires it hasn't typical z-pak is to 250
milligrams tablets on day one followed
by one tablet on days two to five for
use as an antibiotic to treat bacterial
infections when Peter Navarro says this
is the protocol people will hear it and
they'll think that's the protocol for
coronavirus which of course it is not
and in fact we have yet another preprint
of a peer-reviewed study which says that
short-term chloroquine treatment is safe
when you add a zero Meissen it can cause
heart failure and cardiovascular
mortality that is also separate from
whether it even works on kovat 19 and
that data remains unclear and then we go
to congresswoman Marsha Blackburn using
language that to the average Fox News
viewer will imply China sent the virus
possibly as a bio weapon oh one of the
things I think should happen with the UN
Human Rights Council and the wh oh my
goodness here we have China being
protected by the WTO and then they're
wanting to have this seat on the UN
Human Rights Council maybe it's time to
review the funding that we sent to them
maybe it is time to send that message is
that what China did listen China is not
our friend they are our enemy they
haven't been ripping us off taking our
jobs they have been sending us this
virus this year they've been stealing
our intellectual property and we need to
realize they are not our friend they are
part of the new axis of evil you've got
North Korea and China and Iran and
Russia and judge these are not people
who wish us well so a few things there
and of course the ignorance is stunning
to the average fox news viewer when you
say China sent us the virus it's going
to sound to them like this was a bio
weapon number two Blackburn has this
incredibly simplistic understanding of
foreign policy with her whole china's
our enemy and they are aligned with
North Korea there is no doubt and I've
talked about it the Russia China North
Korea situation is one of concern but
the thinking she outlines here in
relation to the virus okay so if we call
China the enemy then what what about
Trump's laughable handling of the virus
so if we call China the enemy then where
do we get on our caseload it was so
bizarre that even judge Jeanine seems
confused by it at one point she also may
have been drinking we just don't know
there's also been a resurgence in the
era of coronavirus with Fox News just
carrying water for Donald Trump you
might remember that over the few months
before the virus we were actually saying
you know Fox occasionally will do
something other than merely parroting
Trump's talking points and repeating
them rare but it happened Fox News is
fully back on board with Trump now it's
very dangerous it's putting people's
lives in danger on a day to day basis
and Judge Janine's show on Saturday
night one of the worst that I've seen
and it is now beyond parody you can't
parody it because the parody is not as
crazy as what is actually taking place
on Fox News have you ever wanted to
learn to play the guitar but you've had
trouble committing to the time and money
required to actually take lessons I have
the perfect solution for you it's called
fender play it's an app developed by the
iconic guitar company fender it lets you
learn to play your favorite songs in
minutes on your schedule with
interactive video lessons that are very
easy to follow you can use it for guitar
bass or ukulele I've been using fender
play to learn the ukulele I've gotten a
lot better than I thought I would in a
couple of months I had tried teaching
myself using some YouTube videos didn't
really get anywhere night and day
difference since I've started using
fender play and they have personalized
learning paths that will cater to your
musical tastes you can use it on your
phone tablet or computer and you learn
at your own pace which is just awesome
one year of membership gives you access
to thousands of lessons for less than
the cost of one traditional in-person
lesson and when you go to fender dot-com
slash Pakman
you'll get to try it totally free for
two whole weeks free two week trial
don't lose out on that without any
commitment that's f en de our comm slash
Pakman PA que ma n fender comm slash
Pakman